et c'est vous Alexandre vaut travers
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue militaire
suisse directeur scientifique également
au Centre d'Histoire et de prospective
militaire vous venez sans doute de
l'entendre il y a quelques instants
volodièreski a considérablement changé
de ton il se dit même aujourd'hui il se
il dit même aujourd'hui comprendre la
posture des Occidentaux qui ne peuvent
pas lui fournir de calendrier quant à
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'OTAN comparé
à ce qu'on a pu entendre hier les doutes
les critiques aussi c'est un peu de
salle deux ambiances non
même négociation si vous me permettez
l'expression donc avant la négociation
avant l'accord et bien évidemment on
cherche à mettre la pression et puis à
partir du moment où les signes ont été
ouverts donc étaient conciliant il n'y a
pas de raison aujourd'hui de l'Ukraine
de la part de l'Ukraine de critiquer ses
propositions d'aide militaires qui sont
quand même très très importantes les
propositions pardon des propositions
dont on connaissait déjà la substance
hier puisque certains chefs d'états
comme Emmanuel Macron avait déjà pris la
parole pour autant ça n'avait pas
empêcher le président ukrainien
d'exprimer ses doutes et d'être très
critique vis-à-vis vis-à-vis des
occidentaux pour une raison très simple
c'est que profil le début de l'année
certains pays membres de l'OTAN ont joué
avec l'idée d'une nouvelle forme de
partenariat c'est à dire d'étendre la
protection de l'OTAN à des états qui ne
seraient pas membres à part entière de
l'OTAN et dans le cadre de ce sommet
c'était effectivement une question
d'actualité puisqu'il y a toute une
série d'acteurs en particulier
l'Australie mais la Corée du Sud le
Japon également qui était présent et
donc il y avait une crainte je dirais
légitime de la part du président
Ukrainiens que l'Ukraine soit relégué à
ce statut de partenaire peut-être un
partenaire privilégié mais pas un membre
de l'OTAN donc on peut estimer
aujourd'hui qu'il est rassuré volody
mirzelinski quand aux intentions des
membres de l'alliance de l'OTAN il y
aura bien adhésion mais plus tard après
la guerre il y a le soltenberg la
confirmé lui aussi
oui et puis je pense que ce qui est
important c'est que
ça intéresse à ce qui se passe sur le
court terme et sur le court terme il a
reçu si je veux dire beaucoup de soutien
de d'appui militaire sur le moyen terme
il a aussi des raisons d'être satisfaits
par les mesures qui ont été prises et en
particulier les programmes de formation
militaire qui ont été mis à disposition
par plusieurs pays membres de l'OTAN et
puis sur le long terme on lui a dit que
d'une part le membership c'est-à-dire le
fait de d'adhérer à l'alliance n'était
pas totalement hors de portée et puis on
allait au conseil au contraire accéléré
et faciliter ce processus d'adhésion on
peut dire effectivement qu'ils ne loin
de repartir les mains vides velody
merzelinski sur le plan militaire les
renforts annoncés ils sont conséquents
très important et je dirais que le
signal de la part de l'OTAN c'est de
dire que cette guerre va durer risque de
durer plusieurs années puisque de durer
très longtemps et dans ce cadre là le
soutien des pays occidentaux et très
très important puisque la capacité de
production la capacité de mettre à
disposition de nouveaux armements des
pays occidentaux et sensiblement plus
important que celle de la Russie qui ne
peut finalement compter que sur sa
propre production d'armement le plus
grand risque a dit
Ian soltenberg il y a quelques instants
c'est la victoire de Vladimir Poutine la
victoire de cette guerre ce serait
possible
alors tout dépend ce que vous appelez
une victoire je pense que du côté russe
aujourd'hui on est assez d'accord sur le
fait qu'une victoire militaire classique
conventionnelle par la conquête d'au
moins 50% du territoire n'est pas
quelque chose qui est véritablement
envisageable en tout cas pas à court ou
à moyen terme donc il faudrait si j'ose
dire une opération de beaucoup plus
longue haleine avec non seulement un
volet militaire mais politique un
lobbying des alliances internationales
alors vous aurez compris que pour la
Russie gagner pour pour la Russie cela
prendra des années pour autant les
Russes maintiennent leur position
tiennent bon on le voit bien chaque jour
la contre-offensive
ukrainienne
marque de très relatifs progrès chaque
jour est-ce que c'est nouveau moyen
c'est renfort militaire que les pays de
l'Alliance viennent d'annoncer ne sont
pas justement le signe que l'on
s'inquiète d'une éventuelle défaite des
Ukrainiens
entre l'annonce de la fourniture de
matériel de guerre et puis l'arrivée de
ce matériel la formation des équipages
vous pouvez bien imaginer qu'il va
s'écouler des mois donc la livraison
d'avions de chasse ou d'avion de
d'attaque au sol qui est annoncé
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui va
prendre quand même plusieurs mois pour
apporter une véritable opération
capacité opérationnelle à l'Ukraine et à
ses forces armées donc je pense pas que
ce soit ça véritablement le problème
maintenant la Russie est dans une
situation militaire relativement
confortable celle que une bonne partie
du territoire
ukrainien et sous le contrôle de cette
armée que les positions ont été
fortifiées que la mobilisation a permis
de doubler les effectifs et donc quelque
part il n'y a pas grand chose à attendre
il n'y a pas de grande opération à mener
en ce moment pour l'armée russe il faut
juste tenir le plus longtemps possible
voilà très bien qui a confirmé hier
qu'il
scrutait avec beaucoup d'attention ce
qui allait se passer à ce sommet de
Vilnius qui ne manquait pas de réagir en
parallèle de cette conférence de presse
de Yann telstenberg et Elodie
marzelinski les Russes promettent
d'ailleurs des contre-mesures si Kiev
utiliser des bombes à sous-munition là
aussi on est dans le jeu diplomatique
oui c'est un refrain c'est à dire que à
chaque nouvelle arme qui proposer tout
d'abord la Russie nous apprend que c'est
contraire au droit et à la morale
ensuite offert un certain nombre de
menaces ensuite dit que l'efficacité sur
le terrain est nul et puis ensuite on
reçoit des communiqués en disant que
toutes ces armes ont été neutralisées
sur le champ de bataille donc c'est
devenu quelque chose de d'assez cyclique
d'assez répétitif pour autant c'est ces
nouvelles armes dont on a entendu parler
les miss escales notamment annoncé par
les Français hier ça peut vraiment
changer la donne
alors plusieurs choses les armes à
soumission ce sont des armes qui ont ou
des munitions qui ont des efficacité
tout à fait considérable on peut
pratiquement dire que c'est munitions
d'artillerie ont quatre fois plus
d'efficacité que les munitions
classiques donc elles rivalise avec des
projectiles guidés et bien sûr à une
fraction du coup de ces armes guidées et
donc du point de vue américain c'est une
possibilité d'assurer vraiment le
renforcement la capacité de continuer à
mener ces opérations militaires pour
l'Ukraine sur le long terme pour ce qui
est du scalpes Storm Shadow britannique
plus de 200 de ces armes ont déjà été
engagés à ce jour à ma connaissance il y
en a qu'une qui aurait mal fonctionné ou
qui n'aurait pas atteint sa cible donc
c'est quelque chose contre les rues plus
contre laquelle les Russes n'ont
absolument aucune parade puisque c'est
une arme furtive très efficace et très
précise et on peut dire que pour la
Russie cela signifie que toute
infrastructures militaire qui serait à
moins de 150 km du fond pourrait être
ciblées et très probablement détruite
par une telle arbre Alexandre au travers
pour conclure peut-être on a vu que
l'Ukraine avait si ce n'est écrasé
largement dominé ce sommet de l'OTAN il
y avait-il d'autres enjeux
évidemment la question de l'adhésion de
la Suède est quelque chose de
faire ce que c'est un signal très très
fort de résolution et d'unité contre la
Russie on fait en réalité les accès
maritimes de la Russie donc sur le plan
pas seulement militaire mais sur le plan
commercial également et puis la Suède
tout comme la Finlande à un certain
nombre d'atouts ou de capacités
intéressantes pour les autres
partenaires de l'OTAN en particulier une
industrie d'armement qui était
extrêmement forte extrêmement importante
c'est aussi peut-être un premier pas
vers la livraison d'avions de combat qui
ne serait pas uniquement de provenance
ou d'origine américaine mais des avions
suédois qui pourraient également être
fournis à l'Ukraine et puis il y a
d'autres mesures d'autres discussions
qui ont eu lieu beaucoup plus vaste et
là il s'agit de partenariats privilégié
avec un certain nombre d'acteurs en Asie
donc le signal est très fort contre la
Chine voilà effectivement un Pékin
toujours au cœur de l'attention merci
beaucoup Alexandre travers merci d'avoir
été notre